sacked by the Prime Minister but many
are asking if he should have gone
earlier on Monday Rishi sunak ordered an
investigation into allegations
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi paid 6 million dollars including
a penalty to settle a dispute with the
tax authorities known as hmrc now he's
written to zahawi saying following the
completion of the independent advisors
investigation the findings of which he
has shared with us both it is clear that
there's been a serious breach of the
ministerial code the report criticizes
zahawi for several failings he didn't
mention an hmrc investigation started in
2021 in his register of interests until
last summer that was after then prime
minister Boris Johnson had made him
Chancellor of the exchequer last October
when Rishi sunak appointed him party
chair and Minister without portfolio so
how we failed to mention he'd paid a
penalty following his sacking many in
the area zahari represents in Parliament
was scathing I think it brings shame on
the town shame on the country
and shame on the party that he
represents well I think it's obviously
called for you know if he's tried to
push things under the carpet and not
declared certain things then it's
obviously deserved isn't it speaking on
Thursday the Prime Minister insisted he
acted as soon as any concerns were
raised
well when I appointed nadeems that are
we to his current job no issues were
raised with me about that appointment
it's really important to say but because
Nadeem zahali himself put a statement
into the public domain and there was
other reporting there are questions to
answer and that's why I asked the
independent advisor to conduct an
investigation to fully establish the
facts but the opposition labor party
says it's not good enough but I think it
does speak to his weakness that it's
taken him so long to act but this isn't
just about Nadim zahawi we had swella
bravaman who also brought the
ministerial called and then was
appointed back into government as Home
Secretary a cross-party committee in
Parliament concluded that reappointment
set a dangerous precedent when it comes
to how breaches of the ministerial code
are dealt with now questions are being
asked about how much Rishi sunak knew of
Nadim zahawi's investigation by the tax
authorities and when
still on the horizon an investigation
into numerous complaints of bullying by
Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Raab
and a parliamentary inquiry into whether
Boris Johnson misled the House of
Commons over drinking sessions held
during pandemic lockdowns known as the
partygate Scandal the Prime Minister
took off his promising integrity and
accountability those themes won't be
disappearing for a while Nadeem Barber
Al Jazeera London